hallo herzlich willkommen denn meine
taten welt heute mache ich eine banana
split rolle das ist eine schokoladen
rolle mit einer quark sahne creme mit
schoko tropfen und einer banane und
diese banana split rolle wollen sich
optisch etwas aufwerten und habe eine
giraffen optik mit eingearbeitet
das bild hatte ich mal bei facebook
irgendwo entdeckt viele von euch haben
sie mir auch schon geschickt ich soll
mal wieder zeigen wie das geht
das möchte ich eben in diesem video auf
die verzichten möchte und nur eine
banana split rolle machen möchte kann
den ersten teil mit der mutterrolle also
mit diesem osterzeit weglassen und
einfach da starten wo ich den bis mittag
hersteller jetzt zeige ich einmal die
zutaten für den muster teig und zeige
euch im anschluss gleich wie das
funktioniert
hier habe ich die zutaten für die muster
creme und zwar braucht ihr einen 130
gramm butter die habe ich in der
mikrowelle etwas erwärmt damit sie
flüssig wird 40 gramm mehl und 30 gramm
zucker und ich werde jetzt meine muster
kremheller lassen deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier auf 40 kommen falls ihr es
mit einem anderen rezept macht und
vielleicht die muster creme dunkel haben
wollte und den restlichen tag hält
können nur 20 gramm mehl und 20 von kaka
nehmen oder einfach dem mehl etwas farbe
hinzufügen und hier habe ich meine
vorbereitetes backpapier auf der
rückseite habe ich es musste aufgewandt
das ist so floss wie meine backform ich
nehme da ja ganz gern meinen lumera
backblech und werde später wenn ich dann
den teig draufgeht noch den lohmarer
back hand aufgeben
aber jetzt für die muster rolle braucht
ihr das nicht weil er die eben einfriert
oder vorwerk das letzte mal habe ich
sehr eingefroren mit dem ergebnis reiche
es nicht so 100 prozent zufrieden
deswegen probiert's dieses mal mit dem
backen und zeigen wir jetzt erstmal wie
man die muster creme macht dafür gebe
ich jetzt einfach alle zutaten in eine
kleine rührschüssel
das berühre ich einfach hat hier noch
die restliche butter aus die fehlt
nämlich merklich um so sollte dann auch
die konsistenz sein
zu fest
deswegen gehe ich da jetzt einfach einen
schluck milch ryanair könnte war einfach
nur ein bisschen butter hingegen kommt
natürlich immer darauf an wie groß es
ist mein zweitgrößte rtl wieder besser
so ist es
ich fände das ganze jetzt mit einem
spritzbeutel aufspritzen hier habe ich
eine lok hülle in größe 2 die habe ich
mir mal auf dem maimarkt gekauft fertig
aber gut online bestellen
ich glaube kaiser hat mittlerweile auch
viele loch tönen im angebot
es geht aber auch ganz gut mit einem
einwegspritze bei dem wir vorne eine
spitze abschneidet oder eben mit einem
gefrierbeutel aber mit seiner läuft oder
ist es einfach schön fest und damit
könnte richtig schöne muster spritzen da
fühle ich jetzt den teig rein
mit der lok kühle mache ich das jetzt
auch zum ersten mal aber ihr solltet
euch auch hier erst mal so einen strich
ziehen um zu gucken ob die konsistenz
stimmt wie ihr damit zurechtkommt da
oben drehe ich das alles schön zu dass
wir oben nichts raus läuft
und jetzt fange ich an mein muster zu
spritzen
und wenn ihr dann mit dem ergebnis
zufrieden sei könne es dann auch backen
also wenn euch manche stellen nicht so
gut gefahren könnt ihr auch noch mal
ausbessern
aber das wird das später dann sowieso
gebacken und das sieht man aber auch gar
nicht mehr
findest du ziemlich gut
das backpapier einschneiden den ecken
damit bleibt und schön flach liegt und
so werde ich das jetzt bei etwa 160 grad
ich würde mal sagen so zwei bis vier
minuten backen ist seht ihr dann dass
die oberfläche festwirt und ist soll ja
auch nicht dunkel werden einfach so dass
später das muster nicht verschmiert wenn
da der dunkle darüber kommt so sieht es
musste jetzt aus ich habe es vier
minuten bei 165 grad gebacken länger
würde ich es auch gar nicht backen
ich habe hier auch eine kleine stäbchen
foto gemacht und das muss ja jetzt nicht
ganz durch seine wo kann ich das jetzt
kurz zur seite stellen und den biskuit
teig herstellen
ich habe ja bereits schon mal ein
grundrezept video von meinen whiskey
teil gezeigt jetzt habe ich noch den
tipp bekommen
ich soll etwas weniger wasser benutzen
diesen titel hat mir der peter gegeben
der peter ist ein konditor und gibt mir
zahlreiche tipps und tricks über
facebook und über e mail
da freue ich mich wirklich immer sei
doch überhaupt auch bisher alles gelesen
konnte nur noch nicht alles und setzen
auf jeden fall wollte ich mich ganz
herzlich bei dir dafür bedanken auch
wenn es in
besser immer und jetzt habe ich mal das
wasser komplett weggelassen in meinem
bisky teig und weil es einfach mal
schauen wer wird die zutaten findet bis
geteilt habe ich etwas reduziert ich
habe früher immer für diese bananen
rolle des kit rezept mit 4 1 angenommen
und jetzt haben es einfach mal
runtergerechnet auf 3 weil mit der teig
einfach zu viel war in dieser
biskuitrolle und ich denke mit 3 1 kommt
man da auch ganz gut hin und zeige mich
jetzt einmal geht es eben jetzt muss ich
mir für den schokoladen biscuit braucht
ihr 380 gramm zucker 50 gramm mehl 50
gramm stärke einen halben teelöffel
backpulver 90 kam unser pulver zuerst
verlief die eier verrührt und während
dem rühren
gebt ihr da den ganzen zucker rein und
lasst es richtig schön steif schlagen
ihr seht ihr wie schön luftig und flut
wichtige eier masse geworden ist und den
rest arbeite ich jetzt auch mit der hand
ein also mit dem teig schaber oder
schneebesen freiburg mitteilt wird lucia
wenn ihr mehl und die trockenen zwar
noch siebter das habe ich nicht gemacht
ich mache auch nicht jedes mal ehrlich
gesagt nur wenn ich gerade lust habe
aber er wird dadurch wirklich etwas
flüssiger ihr habt auf keinen fall
klümpchen 3 und das gebe ich jetzt schön
sie ist schneebesen und stand von außen
nach innen
hier habe ich jetzt noch meinen vakant
um ein muster gelegt ich benutze den
bakken von nomura weil ein normales
backblech benutzt hat er diesen schritt
nicht und ich habe das muster noch mit
einem küchentuch aufgedeckt weil nun
abkühlen damit einfach nicht so sehr
austrocknet weil ich angst habe dass mir
das später bricht jetzt gebe ich da
einfach vorsichtig den teig drauf schön
verstreichen und ihr seht ihr jetzt kann
ja das muster gar nicht verschmieren wir
beim letzten mal
und so werde ich jetzt die rolle bei 175
grad etwa 10 bis 15 minuten backen
das kommt natürlich darauf an wie
schnell ein backofen backt ich sage euch
danach wie immer auch wie lange er bei
mir gebraucht hat damit dass etwa
einschätzen können
so sieht der bis jetzt aus er war
insgesamt zwölf minuten im ofen zu lösen
stellen den bug ran
und ich finde dieser bat combs hat die
perfekte größe für bis mit rolle nehme
ich mir ein stück backpapier stirbt
einmal die platte um
wenn ich die sprache hier abziehen und
sehr schöne muster
jetzt kommt da ein feuchtes küchentuch
und jetzt kann ich das schön von der
langen seite her aufrollen
vorsichtig und ich nehme da ganz gerne
ein feuchtes tuch und nicht so ein tuch
mit zucker das haben ja viele rezepte
dass man daneben soll was mit zucker
bestäubt wird das finde ich erstens zu
süß und zweitens besteht so dann die
gefahr dass der bizkit austrocknet und
mit diesem feuchten küchentuch passiert
es eben nicht das stelle ich jetzt
einfach zur seite und das komplett
auskühlen
ich habe jetzt schon gesehen darf sich
das muster etwas vom teig löst das heißt
es wird wirklich reichen wenn ihr das
muster drei minuten takt und danach den
biss gezeigt drauf gibt um dann
gemeinsam noch mal etwa zwölf minuten
takt so lang hat jetzt eben bei mir
gedauert
ich denke da verbinden sich die zweige
auch besser miteinander und dann kann
man das später auch besser verarbeiten
für die füllung braucht ihr 300 g
schlagsahne die habe ich jetzt schon in
ein hohes gefäß gegeben
ihr braucht 250 gramm magerquark 60
gramm puderzucker den saft einer halben
zitrone dann habe ich schon ausgepresst
ein paar schoko tröpfchen so etwa 50
gramm etwas salat oder sahne steif und
zwei bananen
wie ihr seht sie meine banalen schon
etwas reifer und es dürfen sie auch sein
sie sollen hier richtig schön reif und
süß sein so schmecken bananen im kuchen
nämlich am besten zuerst werde ich es
die sahne schlagen und stadt lebe ich
jetzt drei telefon ab hat mit dazu das
hilft einfach dass die sahne länger
stadt bleibt ihr könnt aber auch
sahnesteif nehmen
kühlschrank und nehme mit dem quark
butter zucker und zitronensaft und auch
da kommen jetzt drei teelöffel seiner
partei ein
könnte hier auch schon die sahne
unterheben
dann könnt ihr hier auch schon so etwa
50 gramm zucker trocken mit einrühren
einfach unterheben
die banane schälen jetzt nehme ich mir
meine biskuitrolle und rolle sie
vorsichtig auseinander
ganz vorsichtig da kommt jetzt die creme
rhein am rand nicht so sehr damit es
nicht raus läuft
das ist so etwa 1 cm bis zwei freilassen
und dann leg ich da einfach die banane
rein
und holte biskuitrolle auf unternehmen
dort schön das tuch zur hilfe gutes
passiert so viel ist nämlich auch weg
sonst hängt es gleich in meinem
küchentuch und strich genug dran schön
sauber das gleich auch auf der anderen
seite dann nehme ich mir meine kuchen
platte und selbst die rolle mit meinem
tuch drauf
und kann dann mit hilfe eines messers
die rolle anheben und das tuch oder
wegsehen und es sieht jetzt auch schon
in meiner küche
es ist ziemlich warm deswegen läuft
alles gleich die sonne raus jetzt gebe
ich die rolle ganz schnell wieder in den
kühlschrank damit sie da fest werden die
biskuitrolle reiz etwa eineinhalb
stunden im kühlschrank
jetzt werde ich sie mal anschneiden
so sieht sie von innen raus und ihr
könnt die banane theoretisch auch in
stücken mit rein geben aber ich finde es
so eigentlich ziemlich schön wenn man
dann ein stückchen bananen hat ich hoffe
das rezept gefällt euch und ich bekomme
zahlreiche fotos auf facebook falls ihr
diese bizkit rolle auch nach macht ihr
könnt ihr natürlich auch mit anderen
dingen füllen ist da keine banana split
rolle machen
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch eine
zitronencreme mit einer weiten oder eine
früchte creme
ihr könnt auch die app cremig
philadelphia nehmen oder meine
waldfrucht creme von meiner
schokoladentorte die ich auf meinem blog
mal vorgestellt würde ich euch viel spaß
und nachmachen habt eine schöne zeit und
genießt das wetter und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bis bald